Yes
, thank you very much dear widower, ladies and gentlemen, I
am very happy to be here with you today
and in
fact I was asked to give a keynote
on the
topic that you are discussing restart these are topics
that you are now discussing here on your
Economic summits debate the
modernization of the economy and
society
and the transformation to a
sustainable form of life and
work that maintains the health of the
planet and the
livelihoods of people that are of fundamental
importance  precisely these issues are at the
center of our agenda we launched
the european green
deal and that gives europe something
why we are
the envy of many other regions in the world today we have
a common vision for a
sustainable future
that's a lot that's good  but of
course that's not enough  dend is
this vision to implement this plan and to
implement it
quickly and that is why we passed
the first european climate
law in the spring, which all
27 member states have agreed on, which
means it is no longer a question of whether,
but only of how
and with it  our targets for
2030 and 2050 have also been enshrined in binding
law,
and then this summer my commission
presented a very detailed
timetable on how we can implement the
european green deal, sector by
sector, branch by branch, step
by step,
and finally we have the
necessary investment funds
provided for the very first time there
is a common european
raising of capital for reforms and
investments we call this
development plan next generation
and if you look at it together
with the eu budget
then we are providing
up to 2.1 million euros in the coming years
a third of that  around 700 billion
euros go to projects of the european
green deal
and the basic principle of the european
green much is
clear science shows without a doubt that
greenhouse gases such as co2 or methane destroy the
climate and thus our basis of life
and therefore only co2 have a
noticeable price who pays imitations
and who wants to avoid it  is looking for
new paths through innovation and clean technologies,
which means that a co2 price also
becomes an innovation driver and these
new paths or
to name your event
we support this new start with all our might with
public and private investments
and of course with the right ones
framework legislation our goal is a resource-saving co2-free circular economy and
everything is based on this logic
emissions trading should be expanded from electricity and
industry where it is today to buildings
and transport it must be accompanied
by reliable social
compensation that is in  the social
market economy is correct and it must
receive massive private and public investments and for this
the right framework conditions must also be
given by our legislation
this does not only apply to europe this
principle a price on co2 social compensation framework legislation
and
investments this principle must
apply worldwide the in addition to the
transformation in europe, it is
at least as important to tackle the
transformation in other regions of the
world
we all know the
starting point is dramatic you only need to look at the
most recent report of the united nations
climate council,
the world community is controlling it at the moment if
you look at the status quo
we are all approaching global warming of 27 degrees celsius
and we all still remember the floods in
germany and belgium but also the
forest fires of this summer
not to mention the
island states the sea is sinking the
forest fires in siberia the one flat  e
twice as big as austria
have destroyed drought floods for the first
time a tornado in the czech republic and many
other consequences of climate change
we must act now this
decade will decide whether we are only
being driven by climate change
or whether we are still in the driver’s seat of
action  keep it in hand
when i look at the result in
glasgow now, it is just
an intermediate
step to keep the global community on board on the way to the 15 degree
target the result has
light and shadow it is good that
climate neutrality is recognized as a common goal
and now that we are moving to the new
standard, it
is also good that for the first time
there is an interim target for the world in 20 30,
namely a reduction of
greenhouse gas emissions by 45 percent
and there is also consensus that we
must become faster and that helps
in the acceleration that we in
glasgow  on a methodology to a certain extent
rules for comparability ge
agreed that is the so-called road book
and
because we have to become faster,
the world will meet again next year
in egypt where the starters should then
formulate more ambitious goals,
especially those that fell short of expectations in
glasgow,
but you also have to mention the shadow
and  the shadow already includes the
lack of clear commitment, goals and
steps set by the global
community and
the shadow also includes the fact
that the poorer countries in glasgow are still
not sufficiently supported financially
by the main polluters, i.e. the
industrialized countries, more was promised in paris
and this  Europe has
fulfilled promises but others have not,
and one of the disappointments is that the
coal phase-out was only
watered down to coal mining, and that at the
very last minute,
ladies and gentlemen, I am firmly
convinced that there is only one
sensible way forward, namely
the gr  üne and digital transformation more
resolutely and quickly
and i am also firmly convinced
that this pioneering role,
if we take it, can become a great opportunity
for europe and germany
i would like to give a few examples of how
this combined power of the european
union
shapes global markets and  this
also opens up new opportunities, of course
, we take europe's commitment to the climate
this commitment to the climate also strengthens, for
example, the global role of our
currency the euro is a very central
pillar in this is our development program
next generation with 800 billion euros
for the first time we are taking on this
scale  capital together as europeans
and for the first
time we are also relying
on sustainable bonds the so-called
green bonds
about a third of next generation
eu is financed by these green bonds
that is more than 250 billion euros
and i will give you one  comparison
germany currently has 17
billion euros in green federal bonds
250 billion euros through the
european union and next generation
next generation you is by
far the largest green bond program in the
world
and europe is thus becoming the world’s
largest issuer of sustainable bonds
this in turn also strengthens our
common  currency
the euro is already the first
choice for sustainable finance today, 50 percent of
all sustainable financial instruments are issued in the
euro and, for
example, only 27 percent in dollars for comparison
, there is also the fact that these green
bonns are massively oversubscribed when
we issue them, which means we will
now do everything  we are working
to expand this position further, but
the truth is
that the european union is
ultimately only responsible for eight percent of global co2 emissions
and
that is why we need the rest of the world
to achieve the 1.5 degree target
and the rest of the world  needs  but also
europe to make successful progress on the way
some countries lack the
means others the technology or the
political assertiveness and
for these reasons we as europeans want to build
global gateway partnerships
all over the world in africa but also
in asia as well as latin america
the european commission
will present a corresponding strategy in the next few weeks,
it's all about
connectivity infrastructure projects and we will
mobilize sufficient funds to make global gateway
a powerful instrument in europe
,
because let's not fool ourselves in this
area either if we europeans do
n't do it  then others
will be there so we will make
investments in africa to create a market for green
hydrogen that will then connect the
two coasts of the mediterranean sea
together we will, for
example, work together with our partners
in
decarbonisation i  invest good
example south africa there we are investing
together in the coal phase-out
and thus creating new sustainable jobs
germany and france
are also involved
a great advantage is
that europe has a reputation as a fair,
reliable partner
and it should not be forgotten that the
european union is the largest
single market in the  world
this makes europe an attractive
a convincing partner
and europe does not invest in
depending on others
but in the fair exchange of knowledge,
services and goods, and so
we ultimately invest in
partnerships that convey our values
nnect people, ladi
e
and gentlemen, shape markets and
creating new opportunities this
also applies to my second point,
digitization
, we are currently discussing intensively how
much power the large
internet platforms can actually exert
. today, the large internet
platforms determine who trades with their help  are
allowed to rub or communicate
they are now something like
digital
gatekeepers who are
able to restrict market access until they
get a share of the earnings or the flow of
data
and that has its price in the
end it is the
consumers who
pay this price and  with the
disclosure of personal data that works
with every click, no matter whether shopping on the net,
reading the news or
looking for information
and the platform
is less interested in what I did
yesterday, their interest is in
what I will do tomorrow and why I do it
do
it's about predicting my behavior
and even more it's about influencing my
behavior
now we voluntarily disclose our intentions wishes
and habits
we do this in return for
services digital
services that make our lives
easier
in the analogue world there are rules
for that  to a certain extent  ality securing the
location and offering protection and
that must also exist in the digital
world as in europe we have it in
our hands we can design our own access to the
digital world according to our
standards
if we look around in the
usa the market traditionally comes first
and the government is
reluctant
in principle in china it is exactly the opposite
the government decides on the
use of data
and the individual has
to accept a subordinate role compared to the
group
europe on the other hand has a long tradition
a long tradition of the power of state
and market in balance  and
at the same time give the individual
special
priority to put people first
for us, a new technology is
never a reason to redefine our values
r us the individual is not j
st part of a mass it is not just
customer or data point  among many
the individual is primarily e  in
human beings with rights and control over
their own lives
analogue or digital
these rights must be protected with
european legislation
and my commission has presented the
digital services act and the digital
markets act for this the abbreviation is
dsa and dma to put it
simply we want to
implement that the  the rules of the analog
world will also apply in the digital world in future
we demand, for example, that the largest
platforms create transparency about
how their algorithms work
because it cannot be that
decisions that have far-reaching
effects, for example on the civil exchange of
opinions in our democracy
, are made by computer
programs that  no one can understand
let alone control
my commission has
already made its legislative proposal in the
coming weeks the council and
the european parliament will
determine their negotiating position and we
can do it already in the coming
year and between  ar in the first half of the
year under the french
presidency to ensure
that everything is set it would be
the first
comprehensive set of rules for the large
gatekeeper platform made in europe worldwide
but of course digitization is much
broader than a platform and how important
resilient global connections are
we learned
from the pandemic not least in the supply chains and that is
my last point
we all see the
difficulties our dependence
on microchips from asia is
causing us at the moment entire factories in the european union
are standing still because the chips are missing if
you look at car sales  looks in
europe they have recently fallen
by 25 percent compared to september 2020
and that although the
demand is booming
and you know it yourself other
important sectors are also affected such as
the market for medical devices or
for energy networks and so on and
so forth
the reason for this  is not  only a
short-term imbalance of supply
and demand
the main reason is that 70
percent of the world's independent chip
production is in the hands of only two
large manufacturers, both of which are based in
east asia
this is not sustainable for us we
know exactly the markets of the future
are hanging on  this product and only those who can produce
the next generation of semiconductors in large quantities
will retain their
technological and economic
independence
and that is why we will
present a plan in the first half of 20 22
and, together with the member
states, provide funds to implement
it it is about the so-called european
chips
we want to ensure that companies producing in europe
have a 20 percent share of
this rapidly growing world market by 8.30 p.m.
today our market
share has fallen to 10 percent that is too little far
too little and the prerequisites
for achieving this goal are met  but good in
europe we have
top european research, for example with imac in which
we have a really strong
industrial base, for example with
sml in the netherlands and we have an
attractive ecosystem in dresden, for
example silicon saxony they say
and we have the market with 450
million europeans  and europeans
that means together if we
can and want to do it right we were and want to
strengthen
europe's technological sovereignty ladies and gentlemen these are just a
few examples of what europe can contribute to the
future you
can see that a fresh start for
germany contains quite a lot of
europe and  that's why i'm looking forward to
working with the next
federal government and, of course, to
the discussion with you now, thank you very much